the right of return is one of the
biggest sticking points in the
palestinian-israeli conflict but what is
it Palestinians who make up the world's
biggest refugee population say they have
a right to go back to the homes that
land they were expelled from when Israel
was created in 1948 Israel says it
doesn't have to accommodate Palestinians
who fled their homes returning
Palestinians would outnumber Israeli
Jews and that would alter the Jewish
character of the state but UN resolution
194 says Palestinian refugees shouldn't
be allowed to return to their homes and
that those who choose not to should be
compensated for the property they lost
where exactly is Palestine to answer
that we need to go back to 1917
that's when British forces captured an
Arab majority region